right now another must-win situation
the third one today four magnus carlsen
here we go here we go queen spawn
opening and there has still been this
pattern of whoever strikes back in
normal time in the rapid portion just
failing to kind of convert in the
playoffs in the blitz and okay magnus
uh thinking
not sure he knows the game has started
maybe he's just getting his music ready
magnus okay the game has started a
trompovsky attack oh this is a rare one
as well magnus has played it a few times
from the white side
simon i think you've played this before
i have yeah yeah i just um done dvd on
this as well as price price and
your chance of of course
ginger gm actually dvd it's a ginger gem
course on this and uh
um it's very interesting opening very
very it's it actually has a good
pedigree of english players playing it
and this line one of the critical lines
so you're right i mean some of the uh
top english grand masters in the in the
90s they were playing this a lot right
uh white does give up the bishop pair
just like uh he did in the last game but
black's pawn structure hasn't been
shattered black's queen though a bit
misplaced
yeah i think uh here that magnus has
picked quite a good line as black so
he's got the bishop pair he's gone for a
bit of an unbalanced situation uh white
has the space advantage in the center of
the two pawns but long term black is
doing quite well because of the bishops
and this move is quite rare this this
move in the center um it's it's now okay
trying to get some solid formation in
the middle of the board
which i don't know it's gonna be hard to
win from too much of a solid formation
but just got to grind away haven't you i
feel black here magnus just needs to
survive the opening he does have the
bishop head long term so there's
something to grind away for um when you
try to grind you need some small
strategic long-term advantage
um yeah he's just trying to erect this
kind of solid pawn structure and he's
going to hope that
it's going to hold
meanwhile duda fianchettoing is bishop
to this diagonal maybe not
kind of the most obvious way to do it uh
white's bishop will slide behind that
pawn but then it's on a blocked line so
a block diagonal slightly odder seems a
strange place to put the bishop doesn't
it so yeah i wasn't expecting that yeah
i would expected duda to play a move
like the wing porn up two squares
because he loves pushing alice the a
pawn or arie the a pawn
and that would be a normal kind of move
to play in this kind of structure
gaining space
on one of the area board where you don't
have space
but okay getting castled is not um a
terrible idea is it by any means you've
got to move that bishop to get castled
do this light squared bishop won't be as
bad as it was in the last game at least
yeah well maybe that's the secret give
yourself a bad bishop
make your opponent you know think that
they should come at you play
aggressively to punish this
positional offense and then uh win the
counter-attack yeah
meanwhile what's happening with magnus
on the clock he's paused for one minute
here
is there a reason for that i mean i
guess there's a lot of choice but one
minute is a lot in a blitz game that's
one-fifth of his time and he came up
with this night move
a bit of a mysterious one and okay now
he's getting developed so both sides
will just castle their kings
very shortly
and what next
okay there we go both kings are safe
it's just maneuvering now
personally i would choose black here if
anyone just because i have the bishop
pair and i love that long term but white
is solid as a rock that's due to
strategy actually in general he's
maneuvering with his knights and the
center is blocked so nights are pretty
good
in the short term yeah i mean dude's
playing in a very interesting way you
know he hasn't really committed his
pieces or his pawns apart from taking
the center and he's simply asking magnus
how are you going to
react are you going to trade in the
center are you going to perhaps well
there goes the answer the center has
been opened
yeah and dudes are now going on the
attack
pushing this pawn a bit loosening but
makes a lot of sense
seems like they picked up the pace a
little bit and uh especially duda i mean
magnus is uh
well i say only got three minutes but
now he's trying to get his bishops into
the game look at this dude has gone
super aggressive and you did mention
before this game david this is probably
the right approach from duda don't go
too passive go go active in the position
and um
well interesting position why is he
overextended or not yes it's tricky to
say right now i love white's knights and
they're really well placed but um it
could backfire if the position opens up
even more and the black bishops get
uh get firing but okay meanwhile black
bishop dark squad bishop has found a
better diagonal
i'm expecting the white queen now to
come out uh she's got a variety of
squares to choose from
magnus again he's solid but a bit
cramped black's queen will need to
retreat at some point she's too far
ahead she the queens don't want to lead
the army they want to be doing the
damage behind later
duda finds a safe square for his queen
so his dude is planned to simply just to
pile up on that weak d6 pawn
possibly yeah um dude we'll just get his
pieces organized and then he'll look for
weaknesses as you mentioned black's deep
one in the center a bit weak i may be
tempted to move the knight in the center
which looks fantastic
over towards the king side as well does
i'm looking for outposts for my knights
my knights and center look really good
and they probably are but i quite like
having a night around my opponent's king
as well so that's a potentially another
idea
i i i would pick white here slightly i
think um
matter of taste right matter of taste
yeah but black is very solid and i guess
black's got to wait wait for the opening
to occur hope his bishops play an
important part when the opening position
does occur yeah and i like what dude is
doing you know nice natural moves now
the rooks are into the game and it seems
that magnus is like undeveloping his
pieces you know he's now put his queen
back to the starting square and moved it
over
far away from her king
yeah
now this maneuver that you mentioned
simon white's knights repositioning
themselves going towards that black king
that has
maybe feeling uh it's feeling abandoned
right now yeah likewise magnus
re-rooting his knight because his king
needs some protection that's right and
then i mean magnus does have this
weakness this pawn in front of that
night which now white is targeting with
that night and you see a little bit
passive here for black at the moment
but very solid and i think magnus is
just waiting isn't he for his
opportunity at the moment keeping solid
as he can but again white has more space
to maneuver more space is easier it's
easier to play when you have that extra
space so i'm still personally taking
white here at the moment
yeah makes sense and it was interesting
a few moments ago we saw judah screen he
was almost pre-moving he's kind of
itching to just make moves he wants to
maintain that time advantage and looking
at the clocks as well he's got an extra
minute that could be valuable especially
if as you mentioned simon he gets on the
front foot he's the one attacking
defending is so hard on a few seconds
so uh speed wise duda space wise in the
position duda what is he thinking here
david of starting the attack he could do
i mean it's obviously risky but you
could go for it now by moving freddie
the pawn in front of the knight and just
go for black's king because ivanka
pointed out he's hovering is it time to
attack he likes attacking just go for it
punt it this is how you this is how you
take magnus down you've got to go
aggressive against him his mouse is on
the f file i think he's going to move
that knight near the white king forward
towards the blacks uh black's king but
um like you said simon is tempting to
move to the pawn as well we see a
reaction on magnus's face there yeah
he's not looking happy right no
magnus i don't like his position either
it's just too many pieces on bad squares
black has the long-term advantage of
course with the bishop pair with uh kind
of a more compact pawn structure but
while we're in the middle game that is
not going to play a factor in a bit of a
strange one putting his bishop okay on
the edge of the board magnus frowning as
well
this is not an orthodox move because
white's bishop actually does a good job
of protecting his king usually
he just wants to trade it off
uh is he going to trade it off for
blacks light squad bishop that was a
sapphire
i don't like that decision at all i mean
you you often want to keep your lights
yeah i mean as you said david that
bishop of blacks was sleeping yeah
is this his idea to now come in the
middle and try to attack i think he just
wants to force force the issue yeah and
yeah that move would never across my
mind i must admit simon um just spending
two moves trading off your opponent's
poor piece but at least he's got rid of
the bishop pair so now long term it's
not necessarily black who's got the
advantage maybe he's just trying to take
as much risk out of the position as
possible but uh now he has to take care
because he's stopped that knight
from jumping in and that's why he
retreats his knight to the d2 square
and it just feels like black is very
solid
and i quite like the long term prospects
if he survives the next few moves
black solid but
white solid as well i mean duda he's i
don't know what he's listening to but he
seems to be enjoying it
and uh still very very fast on the clock
magnus just struggling for a plan the
black queen needs to improve she's not
great right now the nature of the
position is different now at least it's
blocked
temporarily i guess white still has this
pawn break
that might be annoying magnus i mean
this this again it's just the pawn in
front of the the white knight uh if that
goes forwards you open up lines towards
black's king so you have to constantly
be so that's why magnus is guarded
against that move uh but he's only got a
minute and ten seconds now and he needs
to win this game to get to an armageddon
um
it's not going to be easy for magnus
it's easy at all it feels like dude even
after losing to those last two rapid
games he's adapted to the blitz format a
bit quicker magnus was taking risks in
the first blitz game where you didn't
have time with which to do so i was
going to ask about this move you know is
it so tempting to actually chase away
that night
yeah and and then the whole idea it has
a concrete reason because otherwise you
don't really want me making this type of
move is to put the knight on the e4
square and uh hop in yeah we'll see that
happen in a moment
uh utilizing the fact that black's queen
is actually a bit uncomfortable if you
look at the black queen on the same line
at the bottom is the white rook and
that's why ivanka's
tactic is going to work but
it's not too scary this can be dealt
with you don't capture that knight
because then the black queen would drop
on the d-file you just need to protect
the squares that the white knight wants
to jump into
and uh i think you can do that
just with your bishop there we go
where is this night going you've
committed a lot now for duda you've
pressed all of white's pawns forward and
that means there's a lot of
responsibility some of those pawns might
be weaknesses black's knight which is
terrible it's actually staring at the
pawn that's hard to defend so
uh suddenly it's really urgent the
pressure's on
yeah indeed and and you've got some
weaknesses now for white on the queen
side right this pawn on the queen side
it's a little bit overextended
black's got some good central pawns so
uh duda is now using his time magnus 38
seconds and dude
one minute 40 something like this
uh but he's got a he's got a key moment
here of how he continues right um
because he you know it's it's it could
be overextended those pieces getting
sharp i i think
he has to play an accurate move i mean
something that occurred to me was maybe
just move the queen
to b2 just to get it ready to perhaps uh
do something on the dark squares i mean
if dude doesn't find something energetic
now his position will crumble so he's
spending time at the right moment but
suddenly the time advantage has
disappeared it's just going to become
very random
i think you've got this move yeah i
think you've got to go for it this this
creates some threats uh the point okay
you have to give up pawns a dude
in a position where he only needs to
draw his sacrificing i'm amazed he put
the queen there though why didn't he
keep the queen lined up against the king
side i don't know oh and look at the bar
you guys saying magnus could win this
game he's just a pawn up simply
armageddon
that would be fun
if white doesn't find in any attack
white is just pawn down and
strategically white is busted uh black's
pawns in the center of the board the c
and d pawns are just past they're just
gonna roll down and there we go magnus
is mobilizing those pawns yeah
i think he has has to admit that he's
made a mistake with this queen and yeah
is his queen's totally on the wrong
square he hasn't got a way through to
black's king's side queen is blocked if
it was on a light square you can at
least threaten to open up the position
but even then black can defend and at
the moment i can't see how uh dude is
going to get through here there is that
short of time though that magnus has in
the position that could uh could play a
part dude is lower on the clock now
though
yeah wow
yeah
and uh yeah the problem is black's dark
squared bishop covers the dark squares
black's pawns cover the light squares so
judah has no way through and again it's
that superfluous nights that we talked
about the useless nights the white
knights actually get in each other's way
they both want to be on different
circuits but they're stuck on the same
circuit
and okay dude is reduced to just kind of
waiting moves with the white rook
and uh black's queen blockades i love
this movie blockades any pawn pushes
that he wanted
you wanted to push the white pawns
forward earlier simon i think dude has
missed his opportunity he has yeah dude
now
he went down to 12 seconds
no time it gets blocked big threat on
the board white's knight actually wants
to go to the edge and give a check to
the black king but this can be easily
prevented black's king needs to move you
don't want to or the queen needs to move
you don't want to allow that white
knight that's advanced into black's camp
to deliver any checks
and there we go now no more checks the
king dominates that white knight yeah
it's so difficult to find a move for
duda maybe he has to just
it's kind of lost maybe he just
needs to sacrifice some material i think
he's getting ready to put something next
to the queen here maybe a rook and just
just put the rook up throw the rook all
the way up give it up
but look at those two black pawns
they're rolling it's easy yeah okay but
now there's a big big threat on the
board queen queen is going to come in to
h6 but this is why magnus just goes nope
it's chaos and uh dude is only got a few
seconds on this clock magnus at 20
seconds
is that black kingdom is going to
survive magnus is just actually trying
to give away material in order to secure
his king because he knows the two black
pawns
crazy stuff here it's just very random
and that's that happens when it's this
chaotic when there's attacks for both
sides and you only have a few seconds on
the clock it increases the variability
um you lose your odds and okay magnus is
trying to bully dude now with a queen
trade who doesn't have to avoid that
queen exchange no he's taking it
he's taking it to grab the rook but you
know how can he handle those two pawns
that are going to propel themselves
forward actually we're getting
armageddon
we're gonna get armageddon those two
black pawns are so scary and we saw duda
there he was kind of
nervously kind of moving the mouse back
and forth like half pre-moving half kind
of not committing to his moves but look
at these two black pawns
this one is so close to promotion
and it will cost white his knight at
some point
that white knight is getting kicked away
look at duda leaning back he knows he's
in trouble the pawns are rolling
the bar's going all over the shop
this is blitz chess through and through
anything possible and uh at the moment
white hanging on and yeah he's dropped a
bishop dropped his bishop
blue square
he just left his bishop on priests a
free piece for duda
and this one is going to be decided
magnus blundering again
duder takes it he holds his nerve a
handshake it's over young christoph
doodle wins the match actually a smile
on magnus crosston's face he's blundered
a little bit today the world champion
and he loses the match but he does get
one point for losing in the blitz story
breaks